we're doing what we're supposed to be
doing it's a really great job and i'm
gonna speak for us but i think we're
lucky as
hell
whoopi goldberg joy behar sarah haynes
and sunny hostin yep the view has
returned for its 25th season well
hello
and welcome
welcome to the view
[Applause]
e.t chatted with a co-host about the
legacy of this television mainstay
there's good news when a woman has a
baby in her late years she can
breastfeed standing up
joy an og co-host from day one reflected
on the show's evolution since its debut
back in 1997. we were four at the time
too weren't we we were four at that time
and then it became five so it's much
more fun to have fewer people i think
because you can talk more and you know
more people can yeah we can say more to
each other even it became like i'm gonna
i gotta get a word in here now you know
it was i don't i don't love that but
we've learned how to do that now um but
the opposite of that was being alone in
your house which is what we were for the
past two years and now as we would be
like well what do you think and then all
of a sudden i have to give a speech i
didn't love that i didn't love that i
like the audience i like the camaraderie
i like the fun of it which is what this
is about now today and this is why the
view is popular for this exact reason as
the views moderator whoopi opened up
about what it takes to make cooler heads
prevail amid the hot topics
listen you know the truth of the matter
is
we are all adults and we know how to
behave at a table
and so
if it turns
out that i have to say something
everybody
everyone's we're all paying attention to
each other right you know so we know
when we don't want to cross that thing
and occasionally it happens not very
often but it does happen and
and you know we're we're not 20 year
olds so we do what we know how to do as
grown women the season kicks off without
recently departed co-host megan mccain a
rotating group of guest co-hosts will
fill in at the desk for now but joy
offered some words of wisdom for a
permanent replacement we don't like to
be personal with each other and so
whoever comes in will have to know that
and and
otherwise it won't work well i think
we're going gonna look for uh people
that can hang at this table with these
strong women and bring an opposing view
that is also
um
a good conversation and has chemistry
with the rest of them i mean we're not
looking for fights we never are but we
just want people to have a lively
spirited debate and
show i mean the show is about different
views and showing all sides of every
issue and that's what we're looking for
i'm respectful we like to debate but we
don't like to have fights with each
other so what could the view look like
in the future both sarah and sunny agree
it's hard to picture without mainstays
joy and whoopi
you'd hope the brand would be big enough
to keep going but when you think of it
right now you have you know joy has been
again here since day one literally part
of this
whoopi's leg like
every time i feel the need to say she's
an egot does did you guys know that like
she's this is whoopi goldberg they guide
us each and every day and in the
mornings also but nothing lasts forever
ladies you know
you know what they say the show must go
off the video lasts forever
but this show maybe maybe not we don't
know
not everyone can say that not everyone
lasts 25 seasons man it's kind of
amazing and of course you know there's
more to come we're doing what we're
supposed to be doing this is our this is
our gig and this is
you know
our uh
our gift from
the world because not everybody gets to
have an opinion not everybody gets to
say this is what i think and here's why
and let's talk about this this is a
really great job it's a really great job
and i'm going to speak for us but i
think we're lucky as
hell
we know who we are we know what our
place is in the world and we try to do
the best we can this new season also
marks their return to the studio with a
live audience
it's all right you know
i don't think any of us actually wanted
to leave home where we are you know in
our midst but i think
for uh being gone for almost
two years yeah we did what we know how
to do the only problem having to wear
real clothes again the spanx were
killing me man it felt like riding a
bike for me the clothes or the talking
not the clothes
beautifully done beautifully done